a new book on hbo has given an insight
into the fact that george r.r martin was
not happy with the direction that game
of thrones took towards the end of its
run
in particular the final three seasons
took scrutiny from the acclaimed author
james andrew miller's new book tinderbox
hbo's ruthless pursuit of new frontiers
explores the fact that martin fills his
templates for seasons beyond the
original books plot were largely ignored
the show only had material up to season
six
at this point show runners david benioff
and d.b vice needed to continue writing
for the show with essentially a blank
slate and ideas from martin
it appears as though according to george
r martin's representative paul hass he
felt the show's writers didn't follow
his intentions
hass details in the book that george
loves dan and dave but after season five
he did start to worry about the path
they were going down because george
knows where the story goes
he started saying
you're not following my template the
first five seasons stuck to george's
road map then they went off george's
road map
fans seem to echo martin's concerns as
it's widely known that the last three
seasons came under criticism in
comparison to what came before
the rushed ending of season 7
particularly came under the spotlight
for scrutiny
the book goes on to give more
information about martin's suggestion
that there should have been 10 seasons
of the hbo show to give the writers more
freedom to tie up loose ends
paul hass gives an insight into this as
well as he states
george would fly to new york to have
lunch with former hbo ceo richard
pleppler to beg him to do 10 seasons of
10 episodes because there was enough
material for it and to tell him it would
be a more satisfying and more
entertaining experience
it's clear that martin wanted the show
to run much longer than the 73 episodes
that it did
and has even mentioned in an interview
to variety that he had ideas that could
take the epic to 13 seasons
in the end hass puts the fact that it
only ran to eight down to the fact that
show runners vice and benioff were tired
and wanted to move on with other
projects
it seems as though the network agreed
with martin that they wanted more shows
but the writers wanted to wrap it up
despite the fact that the original game
of thrones run is complete this hasn't
stopped several other related tv
projects from approaching our screens
steve conrad has recently been announced
as executive producer on the adaptation
of martin's duncan egg series a prequel
to game of thrones
amongst other shows conrad is
responsible for the amazon series
patriot on top of current amc stop
motion animation series ultra city
smiths
it seems hbo are busy with game of
thrones prequels at the moment as these
also include 10 000 ships sea snake as
well as three untitled animated series
for hbo max
let me know your thoughts on this latest
news in the comments section down below
and stay tuned for more game of thrones
content